we're going to talk about world tea the
royal family are you a fan of the royal
family not particularly despite the day
for the room don't you love a royal baby
wills and Kate mug Megan and Harry
commemorative plates so a big thing was
made when Prince Harry married Megan
Markel because he was marrying a non
loyal I said marry her no more how good
and then they looked into Megan's family
tree it turned out when he looked into
it that she is distantly related to a
King Edward the third was surprising and
then maybe even more surprising is Kate
Middleton who was also meant to be an on
royal is distantly related to King
Edward the third which means Megan and
Kate are distant cousins is that
surprising
well it turns out lots of people are
related to King edwin third and then
DeGeneres is related to Edward the third
it turns out everyone is related to
royalty at some point everyone is
directly descended from royalty
somewhere in their family and that
includes you as well what we can do this
quickly in fact everyone has two parents
and then they have two parents so
everyone has four grandparents and
everyone has eight great-grandparents
and then sixteen great-great
grandparents and you keep doubling this
up if you went back 30 generations at
about a thousand years you'd end up with
over a billion ancestors direct
ancestors but we all have a billion
direct ancestors so straight away you
can see that the family trees were not
just we don't just have separate family
trees if we look at our family trees we
are far more connected than you think we
are this connected web of families in
fact you only have to go back a few
generations if you looked at your
great-great great-great grandmother you
can actually find out that she might be
your great-great great-great grandmother
in more than one way which means you
don't have
sixty-four great-great great-great
grandparents you have 63 or fewer but
that itself doesn't show that we're all
descended from royalty so we're going to
do a little experiment to show you the
kind of idea because you could argue
that royalties like a special case they
could look they're quarantined off yeah
they could be their whole separate
strand coming let's have a look at how
we are all connected what I'm going to
do let's do a little experiment and I'm
gonna have a population of let's do a
simple thing six people now we're gonna
work out who their parents are going to
be we're going to go back a generation
so we might go back a generation like
this three four five six fact I know I'm
gonna do this a few times let me just
prepare this this population down here
at the bottom of the page this is going
to be the present day this is the
present generation now we're gonna work
out who their parents are and I'm gonna
use dice this we're gonna start with
individual one and their parents was one
and five parent one and parent five up
here let's do this for individual to
that's work out who their parents are
strangely some kind of virgin birth here
but no matter I'm going to persevere
with this so missus just had one parent
five and five okay let's see what
individual she was okay five and six so
so individual three had parents five and
parent six over him it's number five I
know there's some scandalous story there
we're not we're not pretty teeth okay
person four three six
so let's do that three and six and
person five okay 6 and 2 6 and two and
individual six here they related to six
and four six and one two three four okay
so now I should make a note of who's
related to who actually so this person
is related to one in the present day
this person is related to person five
the
person is related to person for in the
present day
this person is related to person six
this person right person five who's been
busy is related to one two and three
person six three four five and six okay
I'm gonna take this back of generation
and see who the grandparents are yeah
this is tedious you explicit way let's
see who the grandparents are related to
in the present day person individual one
is related to all these people via this
child here and also related to personal
five so that's okay so that's still
three four five and six this person is
also related to three four five and six
via this child this person is related to
individual six and that's it this person
is related to one two and three this
person is related to individual four and
which I'm going to take this back
another generation let's keep going
[Music]
okay no I mean something's happened in
this generation that didn't happen
before these two people have no kids
they're not related to anyone in the
present day I'm gonna say an for no one
this person had three children but it's
to all these people all those people and
all those people now they've got the set
one two three four five six
they are related to everyone in the
present day mmm that's interesting what
about the other people
this person is related to what one two
three four children not before set this
person is related to six one two and
three one again five and this person
traits a person four
so we've got some related to everyone in
the present day this generation or this
individual is called our most recent
common ancestor this person is the first
person if we all trace our family tree
back it would be the first person who's
related to everyone in the present day I
know I know this is a grandparent to all
of us isn't that nice
that is nice let's go a few more
generations back so we've got five and
six now this is the person here over
here who had no kids okay five and six
let's do it five and six almost
inconsequential
[Music]
one I think I may be one generation away
and this is the generation I wanted to
get to this has a name this is called
the identical ancestors generation so
what happens at this point is either
you're related to everyone in the
present day or you're related to no one
in the present day and that's always
what's going to happen so if we keep
going back we get to a point with the
first common ancestor and then that kind
of increases as we go back and we get to
a generation where they're related to
everyone or at some point the line died
out and they're related to no one
James it feels like there's one floor in
this argument though your dice are very
arbitrary and very fair yes whereas you
know people like you and me are never
going to marry a princess yeah there are
certain kind that there are certain
people above who there's no chance
they'll be my parents where is your dice
everyone's got a chance of being my
parent you are absolutely you that
you've noticed that problem so this is
just to illustrate a point for now and
what I'm trying to illustrate here is to
show you that there will be a point
where we have identical ancestors and
also I think it's kind of surprisingly
recent I mean we only had to go back one
to three generations to get our most
color our most recent common ancestor
and then I went back another four
generations and everyone was related to
me
so the point I'm trying to make here is
it doesn't take a very long time for us
to be all related to the same ancestors
now you were saying this is not true to
life and I agree this is not true to
life because in this example I'm just as
likely to have two parents who are from
power
as to have one parent from Iceland and
one parent from Australia which is not
real life at all and there are other
problems with this model we've got a
constant population as well we can talk
about that so it's not a growing
population and also we had this strange
problem we had the virgin birth it came
up a few times well we've got we've got
small numbers here if we were talking
about a population of millions then that
mean that's not going to happen so maybe
that would be more accurate
yeah yeah if we just play with the model
first there was a mathematician from
Yale
Joseph Chan who looked at this model and
he came up with a way to estimate when
the most common recent ancestor would
turn up and then the identical ancestors
so our most recent common ancestor so
the estimate for working out that he
called this TN so it's the number of
generations you need to go back based on
the population which is the end part of
this and he wrote it out to be when it's
the solution to this formula 2 to the
power TN equal to N and if you're
familiar with logarithms that's not too
hard then if you're happy with that kind
of thing it would be this the logarithm
to base 2 of n is the most recent common
ancestor generation in my example n was
6 it was to the population of 6 people
and so if I did that it would be log
base 2 of 6 which is 2 point 5 8 so I'm
expecting this to happen three
generations back I think that's exactly
what we got in our experiment three
generations back was the most recent
common ancestor for the identical
ancestor generation Joseph Chang called
this U n and to work that out it's gonna
be equal to one point seven seven times
TN my example then I know what TN is so
it's just one point seven seven x that
figure for what you've got which is four
point five eight so I think I was a bit
unlucky with the example I did I think
it happened seven generations back but
you can see it was roundabout right
now you know what I'm going to ask you
to do plug it in the population of the
world perfect exactly know we've talked
about the limits of this model right so
you need a freedom of movement or
freedom to move between social status so
I'm just going to work on something a
bit smaller to start with we'll go up to
the world I'm coming to that and I'm
gonna work on the population of Europe
and maybe this is going too big itself
but let's say population of Europe let's
imagine there was free movement in
Europe so so what is the population of
Europe I know this it's seven hundred
and forty million as the current
population okay let's go back to our
most recent common ancestor well just
put in that figure it's going to be
twenty nine point five generations I
used and the current population of
Europe to work on out yeah thirty
generations back yeah I reckon that's
about nine hundred thousand years ago I
think we can have a more accurate answer
for this because remember my model had a
stable population it wasn't a growing
population if we want to study a growing
population we should use a figure for
the population at the time of the most
recent common ancestor know what that
would do it now I know it's going to be
about a thousand years ago so now I can
sort of use that figure and get a
slightly more accurate answer for this
so I'm going to do that go a thousand
years back and the population of Europe
was about 65 million so it's log base
two of 65 million this is the sword of
and so I'm expecting and that would be
about twenty five point nine generations
about so twenty six generations back
yeah nine hundred years ago something
eight hundred years ago something like
that and then our identical ancestors
how far do we have to go back this means
everyone in Europe Oh No there are
things you can argue about this we're
doing this for fun everyone in Europe
would be descended from this generation
from everyone who was alive
at this generation if they survived at
all if there's if their family tree did
not die out so presumably that would
include your Royals and including the
Royals exactly so the royal families
survive because we can trace their tree
we can trace their family tree back so
therefore any royal family should be
related to all of us and what generation
is that and so it was UN in this system
which was one point seven seven times
I'm gonna use that figure
twenty six isn't it really twenty five
point nine and that generation forty
five point nine so about forty six
generations ago so I'm thinking that's
about one thousand three hundred years
ago something like that so who was King
one thousand three hundred years ago it
was Charles the great or Charlemagne
he's those are known as he ruled over
what remained of the Roman Empire and
then his kids kind of broke up Europe to
become the current royal families of
Europe and we can chase that trace that
family tree down to the current royal
family that means that everyone who has
European ancestry alive in the present
day is a direct descendant of
Charlemagne no nice not necessarily
Edward the third so if we went back to
our most recent common ancestor well
that's nine hundred years ago something
like that and we don't know who that is
you know that could be a peasant or
royalty or so unknown in between we
don't know who that person is but we do
know that there is a point where we
related to everyone about 1300 years ago
wouldn't it be great to go back in time
and tell that person of their special
role so we'll think of it this way play
this forwards everyone alive today if
their family tree survives will be
related to that generation in 1,000
years time and a direct descendant or
there's a direct ancestor to that
generation and now I was talking about
Europe there because just to keep it
kind of contained so you could do this
for Asia and Africa and you'd have the
pablor me you'd have the equivalent of a
royal family you asked me about the
world and that becomes more complicated
because that's not free movement and so
this is what they did they broke up the
world into continents into countries
into towns they looked at historical
data so they could look at the
populations based on historical records
they looked at migration rates from
country to country from continent to
continent and then to see what is the
generation that contains our most recent
common ancestor what is the identical
ancestor generation now the problem with
this model is the migration rates and
the populations our historical record
we've got things for that and the
migration rates we don't have figures
for that so you kind of have to guess
and see what happened our most recent
common ancestor could be anywhere from
five hundred years ago
this for the world to three thousand
years ago so somewhere between that it
turns out in their model that person
always came from East Asia just part of
the way East Asia is connected to the
rest of the world and then the identical
ancestor population was somewhere
between four thousand years ago and
seven thousand years ago which is
relatively recent if we consider this
idea of chasing our family trees back
through our mothers or through our
fathers which was this idea of
mitochondrial Eve Y chromosome Adam
right our most recent ancestor tracing
back through our mother's or Father's
was about two hundred thousand years ago
but if you take that restriction away
we're just tracing our family trees back
normally then yes about five hundred or
three thousand years ago somewhere there
is our most recent common ancestor of
the whole world so if I went back to
seven thousand years in a time machine
every single person on the planet either
leads to a dead end and has no living
ancestor or is related to me
exactly right in fact the the paper that
they published in nature it's
he's a maths paper but then they ended
it in it's lovely way there's a lovely
sentiment at the end of the paper which
I'm just going to read if you don't mind
no matter the languages we speak or the
colors of our skin we share ancestors
who planted rice on the banks of the
Yangtze who first domesticated horses on
the steps of the Ukraine who hunted
giant sloths in the forests of North and
South America and who labored to build
the great pyramid of khufu and that's
such a beautiful sentiment to end with
six so the average number of kids well I
just add up the values here and divide
by six nine out of six would be the
average it's greater than one